[MUSIC PLAYING]
DARREN KRAHN:
Welcome to our talk
today on device provisioning
and authentication
with Android Things.
My name is Darren.
I'm a software engineer.
And I work on security
for Android Things.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Cool.
So I'm Wayne Piekarski.
I'm a developer advocate
for Android Things and IoT.
And so thanks for coming
today to our talk.
And today, we're going to talk
to you about the strategies
of getting your IoT devices
connected to the internet,
to the cloud, and
everything else.
So we're going to go through
the whole process end to end.
And we're going to talk
about how Google software
platforms, such as Android
Things, Firebase, and Cloud IoT
Core, help to make
this much easier to do.
So, as many of you
probably know--
and that's why you're here
today-- is that IoT is huge.
And it's going to be bigger
than anything we've seen before.
So in the same way that we saw
phones were orders of magnitude
larger than PCs, I
think we're going
to see IoT devices being orders
of magnitude larger than them.
We're going to be
surrounded by IoT devices
on a day-to-day basis
that do all kinds
of different tasks for us.
And there's not going
to be just one device.
You're going to have
tens or hundreds of them
doing all kinds of
interesting things.
And so today, we're going to
give you some hints as to ideas
on how to best build
these kind of IoT devices
and how to connect them,
secure them, and so forth.
So firstly, let's discuss
the basics of Android Things.
Hopefully, most of you
have seen the intro talk.
If you haven't, we
have a bunch of talks
here at IO that cover
what Android Things is.
But the core concept
of Android Things
is that it's based on a
system on a module, which
is shown in the image
over there, which
is the little small board.
And so the SOM contains the
CPU, the Wi-Fi, the memory.
And it's supported by what we
call a board support package.
And this provides the drivers,
the kernels, the libraries,
and everything.
But it also provides updates
and security from Google.
And, using an
Android Thing SOM, it
makes it really easy for
developers to build IoT devices
and also to help ensure
that they're secure
and that they're kept up
to date, because those
are the kind of things
that consumers need now
with their devices.
One other thing that makes
Android Things unique
is that it supports
really powerful types
of processing on device.
So you don't need to
do things in the cloud,
but you can do video
and audio processing,
you can do machine learning,
and you can do everything
on device, because we have
phone-level CPU performance
on these Android Things SOMs.
And the other thing is
that it's based on Android.
So you can use all of the
familiar developer tools
that you're used to, such
as Android Studio and all
the existing code that you have,
if you're an Android developer.
And so you'll be right at
home using Android Things
if you've done Android
development before.
So there are lots
of other talks at IO
that you can go to
learn more about that.
But what we're going
to focus on today
is how we can take advantage
of all these things
that come with Android Things
to make your IoT devices easier
and better for you.
So with that in mind,
let's get into an example
that we're going to use
throughout this talk
to sort of explain what
we're talking about.
So we're going to
build an IoT washing
machine, because why not?
And everyone's excited
about using machine learning
and TensorFlow.
So therefore, we probably should
be using a washing machine that
does machine learning on-board.
It should have a camera
that looks at your laundry.
And then, while it's
washing your clothes,
it does machine
learning algorithms
to analyze how clean it is.
And it can also allow you to
see how your laundry is being
washed when you're
at work, in case
you're interested in seeing
this kind of thing happen.
So I guess we could call our
new product "TensorWash."
So when we build this
"TensorWash" washing machine,
most washing machines still have
a control panel on the front,
because you still want
to control it manually.
Now, because Android
Things supports
really powerful devices,
you could actually
have a screen on the front.
It could run OpenGL.
You could have videos
and audio playing.
So that's one option that
you could build, maybe
in the deluxe model
of the machine.
However, if you want
to reduce the cost
to make a cheap IoT
washing machine,
then you probably want to
get rid of the display.
And so we're going to leave
that out for this example.
So the machine is going
to be IoT enabled.
It's going to have a few
buttons on the front.
But pretty much
everything is going
to be controlled via
a phone, which we're
going to talk about in a bit.
So the real magic of
a machine like this
is when it's connected
to the internet.
And so you can monitor
the machine remotely.
You can view what
the camera sees.
You can trigger off
a wash cycle when
you're at work, when you're
driving home or whatever.
So the user is not in
the house, and they
could be potentially
anywhere in the world.
So we don't want to
restrict it to just being
controlled from something
that's close by in the house.
So we really need to have an
internet cloud-based connection
with some kind of cloud
solution behind that.
And we could add all
kinds of fun features
by having cloud support.
So we could have
it awarding points
for not washing your clothes
or not wasting water too much.
It could report faults
to a service department.
And in order to support all
this, the machine needs Wi-Fi.
And we're not going to
cheat by just plugging
in an ethernet cable into it.
So we have this washing machine.
We need it to
connect to the cloud.
And we need to share
state with the cloud
so that a phone could
control the device.
So there are many
possible cloud services.
We'll talk about a
few of them today.
But firstly, in order to
make this kind of thing work,
we need to firstly get the
device onto the network.
And so many devices these
days are Wi-Fi based,
so the device requires
an SSID and a passphrase
to join the network.
Many devices don't have
a keyboard or a display,
like in the case of
our washing machine,
so everything needs to
be handled by the phone.
And if we use a
phone, then the device
needs to spin up a Wi-Fi
access point of its own.
The phone connects to it.
It sends all the login
[INAUDIBLE] over.
And then the device
reconnects to the network
and uses that information.
And if anything goes
wrong for any reason,
the phone has no way of
knowing what happened.
And so it's a very
delicate process.
And so it can be problematic for
some phones or Wi-Fi networks.
And so many developers find
this challenging to get right.
So we're going to go
through some hints on how
to make this better.
And next, the
device needs to know
who the owners of
the device are,
so you want to make sure
that the device is viewed
and controlled only by the owner
of the device and anyone else
that they trust.
So we need some kind
of authentication token
that needs to be
issued by a server
that the user then uses
to control this token.
We put it on the device.
And then that's what the
device uses to contact
the internet and the cloud.
If the user factory
resets the device,
then we need to forget this
token and everything else.
And then the device
should reset itself
so that a different user
could use the machine,
and none of the previous
history is preserved.
So now, our "TensorWash" is
all connected and ready to go.
So when the phone, device,
and cloud all communicate,
we do that over a TLS
connection, such as HTTPS.
So it's very important that
it's secure in that way.
We don't want to have
eavesdroppers in the middle.
Google services generally
these days require HTTPS.
And we're actually starting
to enforce this by default.
So we're making it
harder now for you
to use unencrypted connections
because of all the security
implications.
And it's important that, when
you build devices like this,
that everyone does
security properly,
even tiny IoT companies
that are making
really simple little toys or
whatever, because everyone
always thinks that their device
is not going to be the problem,
and then even small problems can
have unexpected impacts in ways
that you just didn't
even dream of later
on once your device
is out in the world.
So that's it.
That's the key
concepts of what you
need to get a washing
machine that we're building
and get it connecting
up to the cloud.
So we need to set up Wi-Fi.
We need to transfer
the credentials.
And then we need to
connect with encryption.
But there's actually
a lot more to it.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to let Darren now do a deep
dive on some of the key concepts
here and a bit more
of an explanation
as to what's going on.
DARREN KRAHN: Cool.
So I want to take a step
back and talk about a few
of these key
concepts that we use
to establish secure
relationships between devices,
which is fundamentally
what we're doing
when we provision devices.
These concepts are distinct, but
they're very much intertwined
in practice, as you'll see.
I want to talk about
authentication, authorization,
and attestation.
First, authentication.
To authenticate
something is simply
to prove that it is genuine
or valid, that it's authentic.
We authenticate works of
art, official documents,
handwritten signatures.
We also authenticate each other,
mostly using face recognition.
This is very natural to us.
It's very intuitive.
Computers often authenticate
us using passwords.
Automobiles often
authenticate us using keys.
So we use authentication all
the time in our daily lives
without really even
thinking about it.
But what about
when one computing
device needs to authenticate
to another computing device?
This is less intuitive
for us to think about.
Often, what it involves
is secret data.
So the authentic computer
has access to secret data,
and all the other
computers don't.
And so there's two forms
that this secret data can
take that I want to talk about.
One is cryptographic keys.
And the other is bearer tokens.
There are other ways
to authenticate.
But these are very common,
and they'll directly relate
to our "TensorWash" example.
I'm going to dig into each
one of them a little bit.
So cryptographic
keys and certificates
are very common on the web.
This is how your web browser
would authenticate a web
server--
using HTTPS, for example.
The authentication involves
verifying their certificate,
verifying the information
in the certificate,
verifying it against
something you already trust
or that you expect,
verifying the authority that
issued that certificate is
something that you trust.
We also need to verify the
proof of possession of a key.
The key itself is
not transferred
across the network,
or at least, not
the private part of the key.
But we need to check that the
other computer has possession
of it, and it gives
us a proof of that.
So doing this right in
practice can be really hard.
Building these protocols
can be really hard.
I strongly recommend you
don't build this yourself.
Find a good library
that does it.
If you use Android Things, we
have support for HTTPS and TLS
built in, and so you don't
have to implement any of this.
So I like to compare this
kind of authentication
to an airport passport check.
If you imagine, you
take your passport
and you come up to
the check, the agent
there is going to validate
specific information
on the passport.
They're going to verify
that it is from an authority
that they trust.
And then they're going to do
a proof of possession check,
which, in the case
of the passport,
is a match of the picture
with the face of the person
standing in front of them.
I also want to talk
about bearer tokens.
These work a little
bit differently.
They're passed from one
computer to another in order
to verify them.
They're often opaque
to the computer that
sends it, but
meaningful, of course,
to the computer
that verifies it.
Authentication of the sender
or bearer of the token
is implied by the
authentication of the token.
The verifier looks at
the token and makes
a decision as to whether it's
an authentic token or not.
I like to compare this to the
example of a movie ticket.
You go to the ticket stand,
and you buy a movie ticket.
That ticket becomes
your bearer token.
You go into the
theater, you present
that token, you're allowed in.
You pass that ticket
to your friend.
Your friend is now the
bearer of that token,
and they can get into the movie.
So often, these
kinds of tokens are
used to represent a more
thorough authentication that
happened in the past.
Here's another good example.
On the web, when you have a
website that requires a login,
you log in with the
username and password.
And imagine if you had to
type your password again
for every page within that site.
Navigate to a new page,
type your password again.
It wouldn't be usable.
And so often, what
happens under the hood
is a web server will issue
your browser a bearer token.
And it will live for a
certain amount of time,
and it'll have access to
your account, whatever
that means on that website.
And so you don't have to keep
entering your password all
the time.
And it works the same
way with an IoT device.
You can investigate
it thoroughly once,
issue it a token, and you get
a much lighter authentication
mechanism from
that point forward.
So let's think
about authentication
in the context of IoT.
There's a few aspects that
are worth calling out.
One is that the authentication
needs to go both ways.
The services and other
devices around a device
need to authenticate
that device.
And that device
needs to authenticate
the other services, the
other devices around it.
So for example, a device would
authenticate a web service,
same way that a browser
would authenticate a web
service using HTTPS or TLS.
Also, authentication
does not necessarily
mean a verification of identity.
Often, we think of it that
way, but it doesn't necessarily
have to be that way.
Take the example of a
restricted web service.
Suppose you [INAUDIBLE]
web service,
but it's intended for instances
of your product to connect back
to that web service.
And you want to make sure that
all the clients are actually
instances of that web service.
What you want to
do is authenticate
that it's one of your devices,
but you don't actually
care which one.
You can actually do an anonymous
authentication, in that case.
Also, we need to
bind authentication
to meaningful expectations.
We want to make sure
that we're authenticating
what we're thinking, what we
are expecting to authenticate.
Let me give you a
couple of examples.
If there's a device
in front of you,
and you want to
authenticate that device,
you bind it to
something physical.
Find something
physical in the device.
If the device has
a screen and you
can display a code both on
your phone and on the screen,
for example, that's a physical
binding of that authentication.
That's a common experience
when you do a Bluetooth pairing
or something like that.
But you can also use a sticker
on the device or a barcode.
And we'll talk about
that a little bit more.
Same thing goes with
an encrypted channel.
If you've established
an encrypted channel
and then you need to
authenticate that channel,
bind your authentication
to that channel.
So if you're using a standard
protocol like TLS or HTTPS,
this is already done for you.
You don't have to
worry about it.
But if you're doing some
things between two devices,
for example, and
they don't support
that kind of a protocol, then
you need to think about this.
So let's go back to our
"TensorWash" example
and take a look at
all the authentication
that needs to happen.
So we'll start in the
completely unprovisioned state.
So we just took our "TensorWash"
machine out of the box.
So let's assume that our
smartphone's already set up.
Our smartphone is able to
authenticate web services
using HTTPS, TLS.
And also, in our
case, let's assume
that we have a Google account
we've logged into on the phone.
And so those web services are
able to authenticate the phone.
And so there's a two-way
authenticated relationship
there.
The first thing we
need to do is we
need to authenticate
this new device.
What we want to do is we
want to send it credentials.
Those credentials
can be valuable--
Wi-Fi passwords, access
to cloud services.
And we want to make sure we're
sending it to the right device
before we send it over.
And once we've provisioned that,
we want to end up in the state
where we have two-way
authenticated relationships
between the "TensorWash"
machine and cloud services.
So I've given two
examples here, Firebase
and Cloud IoT Core that we're
going to use with "TensorWash."
And for both of these, we
want a two-way relationship.
Again, authenticating
web services,
we'll use the
standard TLS HTTPS.
And we'll use
different forms, which
we'll talk about in
more detail a little bit
later to authenticate
the device.
But those credentials
are going to be
provisioned during this
process from the phone.
So you may have
noticed that there
is one authentication
that didn't
go both ways in my example.
What about this
one, here in yellow,
from "TensorWash" to the phone.
Is it OK for the "TensorWash"
device to come out of the box
and not authenticate the phone
that's going to set it up?
So we've put it this
way, because it's really
common for consumer devices.
When they come out of the
box, they're in a clear state.
They don't have any notion
of who their owner is
or who they trust.
They're just available
to be set up.
And so we wanted to
build out this case.
And mostly, that's OK.
It doesn't come out of
the box with credentials
that it's going
to be giving out.
It's receiving credentials, and
so it's less important than,
for example, the phone
that needs to authenticate
the "TensorWash" device.
But there are
cases, for example,
in enterprise zero-touch,
mass rollout scenarios,
where you want that device
to come out of the box
and get itself set up.
It'll have to come
out of the box
already with a notion
of who it trusts.
And this can be as simple
as just taking an HTTPS URL
and embedding it onto the
device, so when it wakes up,
it knows where it can go.
And that can be a registration
server that can fill it
in with the rest of the
credentials or the information
it needs to get configured.
But we're going to leave
that bit out for our talk.
And we're going to
assume we have a consumer
device, "TensorWash" coming out
of the box in a clear state.
So we've talked
about authentication,
which is checking whether
something is authentic.
And now, I want to talk
about authorization.
Authorization is checking
whether something is allowed
to do what it's trying to do.
Think back to the
airport passport check.
You arrive at the airport
with a valid passport.
It doesn't mean you're
going to pass the check.
For example, they're
going to be checking
whether you're scheduled
for a flight that day.
Just because your passport
is an authentic passport
doesn't mean you pass.
There's still an
additional authorization.
Similarly, with the
movie ticket scenario,
if you head to the theater with
a movie ticket from last year,
you may not get into your movie.
It's a different time, different
date, different showing.
And there's an
authorization that
happens, even though your movie
ticket is perfectly authentic.
So I want to use the
example of OAuth 2.0, which
is a very commonly
used authorization
framework for the web.
It's built for the web.
It may or may not work
for a given IoT use case.
But it's a good
example, and I want
to pull out a few concepts
that are important.
And even if you
don't use OAuth 2.0,
you need to think about
some of these concepts.
The two big ones are token
scope and token lifetime.
Token scope describes
what privileges
are associated with a token.
So, what can the bearer of
this token get access to?
Token lifetime describes
when the token expires.
And there's this notion
of refresh tokens
versus access tokens.
Access tokens are
going to be used
to access the actual resource
you're trying to get to,
the protected resource.
These tokens are often
short-lived, narrowly scoped.
And it can be self-contained.
So the decision on
the resource server
can be optimized and quick.
And it doesn't need to do
any kind of back-end lookups.
It just looks at the
token that it received,
and it can make a decision
with the information there.
Refresh tokens,
on the other hand,
are used to get new access
tokens when the old access
token expires.
These tokens are
often long-lived.
They're more widely
scoped, so you
may want to go and get access
tokens for of a variety
of different scopes.
And they're not
self-contained specifically.
And what this enables is this
enables the authorization
server that's making the
decision as to whether it
should give a new access token
based on the refresh token.
It can decide if there's
been a revocation
of that authorization.
And that's what you want
to have with IoT as well.
You want to have that
passive expiration.
So if it's revoked, once the
current set of access tokens
expire, there's no more access.
There's no way to go get
another access token.
You don't want to
be in a situation
where you have to pull an unused
IoT device out of a closet,
hope it still boots up, and
do some kind of factory reset
in order to de-authorize it.
You want to be able
to do that passively.
So this is a snippet from
the OAuth spec rfc6749,
depicting the
refresh token flow.
You can see in the
middle, the access token
is used to access a protected
resource and resource server.
In steps E and F, that's where
the access token's expired.
And you'll get an error back.
And then down at
the bottom, G and H,
you can see the
refresh token's used
to go get another access token
from an authorization server.
Hopefully, that
helps you visualize
that a little bit better.
So let's think
about authorization
in the context of IoT,
or of an IoT device.
We talked about
the authentication
needs to go both ways.
Authorization needs to
go both ways as well.
Or at least, we need to think
about it in both directions.
We need to think about who
has access to a device, who
can send commands to the
device, who can read data
from the device, and so forth.
We also need to think about what
does a device have access to?
What rights does it have when
it connects to a web service,
for example?
We want to use the principle
of least privilege.
We don't want to give more
privilege than necessary.
This is a really common
problem with IoT,
and I think it's because
it's so easy to just give
the device total authorization
for the service it's
connecting to, because then you
won't have any more problems.
You won't have any
authorization errors,
and everything will just work.
The problem is if
the device is only
using 10% of that authorization,
if your device gets hacked,
now the attacker has
access to all of it,
even though you
weren't using it.
You also want the expiry.
I talked about the
passive expiration.
You also want to be careful
when you're passing your tokens.
Tokens are, of
course, made to be
passed for specific purposes,
verification for example.
But you want to make
sure that you've
authenticated the recipient
before you send your token.
If you're sending it up to a
web service for verification,
make sure it's over HTTPS.
If you're purchasing
a new device,
like our "TensorWash" case,
authenticate that new device
before you send over the token.
As you'll see in a few minutes,
Google services like Firebase
on Android Things, the Firebase
SDK will manage tokens for you.
You don't have to worry about
this token management, which
is great.
So let's go back and
look at authorization
in our "TensorWash"
scenario specifically.
We start in this state, where
we assume the phone is already
authorized to set up new devices
with these cloud services.
And the phone is
implicitly authorized
to set up the "TensorWash"
device, because it doesn't
have any policies about that.
And where we want to be
after we provision is we
want to have a two-way
authorization with Firebase.
So we're going to use the
Firebase Realtime Database.
And it can sync
down to the device.
It can also sync data from
the device up to the cloud.
And when it syncs
down to the device,
we can actually use that to
issue commands to the device.
And so there's an authorization
where Firebase is authorized
to give commands to the
device, and the device
is authorized to push data
back up into Firebase.
For Cloud IoT Core, we put the
arrow in just one direction,
because what we're going to
be using it for is metrics.
So as the device
is working, it's
pushing metrics up into
the Cloud IoT Core project.
It needs to be
authorized to push
into that particular project.
So we're going to show you the
details of how you set this
all up.
First, I'm want to talk
about one more key concept,
and that is attestation.
Attestation is really proving
the integrity of a computing
device with state, so
including the current operating
state of the device.
So it's really a special
kind of authentication.
In order for this
to be possible,
the device needs to already
have some kind of a credential
that it can use to prove itself.
It often is a provision
of the factory.
So when the device
comes out of the box,
it can already prove that
it's a genuine instance
of that particular product.
It's also worth mentioning
that attestation is often bound
to a cryptographic key.
So instead of the attestation
assertion from the device,
saying, I'm a genuine device
running in a secure mode,
it's a bit more like, this
particular cryptographic key
is securely held
by a genuine device
running in a secure mode.
And this is useful,
because it allows
us to bind the attestation
to something else that
uses the key-- some other
kind of authentication,
for instance.
And you'll see in
the example later
that we use a key like this
to connect to Cloud IoT Core.
So an Android
Thing specifically,
you can attest
various properties.
You can attest that it's
authentic Android Things
device.
You can verify that
it's an instance
of a particular product.
You can verify device identity,
if you need to do that.
You can also verify
device state,
like I was talking about.
And one of the ones that we pull
out is the verified boot state.
When this device is
actually running,
they prove software
for that device.
You can also verify attributes
of the cryptographic key.
And I won't get into that today.
So this is what a
certificate chain looks like.
Five levels deep.
At the top, we have the
Android Things CA, Root CA,
and Intermediate CA.
These are managed by Google.
These are the authority for
all Android Things attestation
certificates.
In the middle, level 3, we
have the product-specific CA.
And this is also
managed by Google,
but it's in the context of
the Android Things developer
console.
And it's associated with
a particular product
on that console.
Every time you go and create
a product on that console,
there's going to be an
intermediate-level CA that's
assigned to that product.
So the next level, we have
the device-specific CA.
And this is provision to
each device in the factory.
This is unique per device.
It contains an ID
for that device.
And when your device
comes out of the box,
this is the one that it has.
The last level is
the application key
and certificate.
So this was generated
on the device.
It was generated by
your application.
And the certificate
is generated as well
by the device-specifics
CA, which
is protected by the
trusted execution
environment on that device.
So back in our
"TensorWash" example,
the attestation happens
here with the arrow,
from the "TensorWash"
device up to the phone.
So when we do that
verification, remember
the phone is going
to verify, it's
going to authenticate
the device.
That's where we're
using attestation.
So a quick review.
We talked about
authentication, checking
that something is
genuine or valid;
authorization, checking
that it is allowed
to do what it's trying
to do; and attestation,
which is checking integrity of
a computing device specifically.
And now, Wayne is
going to show us
how to do all of this
with Android Things.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Cool, thanks.
So now we've discussed
the key concepts.
So now let's talk about
how we build something
like this using the
various pieces that
are available on Android
Things and from other services
that Google provides.
The first step is
we can use something
called Nearby Connections.
And so Nearby
Connections is great,
because it provides an
abstraction layer that
helps to find nearby
devices, and it
establishes an encrypted
communications channel.
So under the hood, it uses
Bluetooth, BLE, Wi-Fi hotspots.
It uses whatever is
available to it at the time.
And the other nice
thing about it,
once the connection
is established,
is it provides a short human
readable code on both sides
that you can display on screens.
Now, many of you
have used devices
where it shows a little
code on the screen.
And that's great, in most cases.
But we mentioned earlier
that the washing machine
doesn't have a screen on it.
So we don't have quite
enough security that we need.
And we're going
to talk about how
to address that in a minute.
But Nearby Connections is
the first building block
that we're going to use.
And so if we look at
some code snippets,
this is just sort of
an abbreviated version
of a Nearby Connection sample.
You can see here that we
create a Nearby Connections
client at the top.
We then specify some
discovery options.
We just used the default
value, P2P cluster.
That doesn't matter so
much what we use here.
And once we start the
discovery process,
we need to have a service ID.
So in this case, it's com
dot example dot tensorwash.
And that is like our product ID.
It's not the name of
your app on Android.
They call it a service ID.
But it's what the name
of your device is,
or whatever you want to call it.
And then we also have an
endpoint discovery callback,
which Nearby Connections
will call your code whenever
a new device is discovered.
And what you would do is
you'd maintain a list view,
and you would have
a UI that updates,
showing all of the devices
that have been discovered--
because clearly, we want
to be able to support
more than one device
being available at a time.
And then once the user has
selected the one they want,
they can pick it.
And then we can
establish a connection.
On the device side,
Nearby supports
a startAdvertising method,
where you basically
provide a human readable
name of the device.
And then you put the
same service ID in.
And then you also
set up some callbacks
that will be called whenever
a connection is established.
So when the user has
selected the device,
so they've picked
it on the screen,
now we need to use the request
connection method, which
will handle establishing
the connection
to the remote endpoint
ID that's been passed in.
Once again, there
are callbacks there.
And then
onConnectionInitiated is
used when the connection
is starting to that device.
And it fills in a
authentication token,
which is that short
code we mentioned.
So Nearby Connections gives you
a short human readable value.
Once again, we don't
have a display,
so we'll talk about how to
deal with that in a minute.
But you can see here,
the code's really simple
to work with Nearby Connections.
And it gets us
going quite quickly.
The next thing, Darren
talked about attestation
and verifying the device.
So we need to make sure that
the device in front of us
is the one that we're
actually connecting to.
So what we do on the
phone is we actually
create what's called
a random challenge.
So it's a random number
that's unique just
for this connection.
And then we send that
over to the device.
And we use this to
prevent replay attacks.
And the device takes
the random challenge.
It combines it with
the authentication code
from Nearby Connections,
brings them together,
and then it uses
this to generate
a new key in the
Android Keystore
with the attestation
certificate chain.
This certificate chain is
then sent back to the phone.
And the phone can
then check it, which
we'll talk about in a minute.
And even though we're
using a random challenge,
the auth code from
Nearby is important,
because it helps to bind it
to the encryption channel
that we're using right now.
And another thing is that
it's also important to rate
limit failed connections.
So what you don't
want is for someone
to be able to constantly
connect your device
and try random codes and try to
get it to generate some keys.
You're better off rate
limiting that to prevent
people attacking your device.
Here's some of the
code that does that.
Don't worry about it too much.
I just wanted to
show you some bits
and pieces of what there is.
But on the device, we have
the authentication token
from Nearby.
We take in the random
challenge that we got earlier.
We combine it together.
We use this code to generate
the signing key here.
And the interesting part about
when you generate something
in the Android Keystore is
that it's done in a trusted
execution environment.
So we don't actually
keep the key in our app.
We actually keep it in the
trusted execution environment.
And this is nice,
because it means
that, even if someone
hacks in our app,
they don't have the ability
to pull out the private key.
So that adds extra security
to what we're doing.
So anyway, we put
all this stuff in.
All those purple values are
all just standard constants
that you use.
So don't worry about
capturing this exactly.
Later on, we're going
to release a sample that
has all of this in it.
But I just wanted to walk
you through a bit of it.
But at the end, you extract
out the certificate chain.
And that is what you then
pass back to the phone for it
to check it and do
whatever it's going to do.
So Darren mentioned earlier the
concept of a certificate chain.
And so the factory
provision attestation key
also comes with a certificate
chain from this leaf
all the way back to the Android
Things root certificate.
So now we have a full chain
for the key we just generated.
So right on the bottom,
that's what we just created.
And it links all the way back
to the Android Things root.
So now "TensorWash"
has generated
it's custom attestation
key and certificate chain.
And we've sent the
chain back to the phone.
So the phone needs
to verify that this
is a legitimate device
that's untampered with
and that it's also the
one in front of us.
It's actually a pretty
tedious process.
There's a number of steps.
And it's probably
something that we should
put in a library in the future.
But the gist of
what you need to do
is you need to verify
that the certificate
chain is connected correctly.
You need to verify that
the root is the trusted
root from Android Things.
You need to verify that
it's your product ID.
You can verify a 128-bit
UUID for the device.
This is something
that, at the factory,
you could actually take and
print on the box with a code
so that the user can verify that
they've actually matched it up
against the one
in front of them.
You can verify the boot status.
When the key is
signed, it's sent over
with a flag
indicating if the boot
loader has been tampered with.
You verify the attestation
challenge, which
we'll talk about in a bit.
And then you end up with a
public key that you can save.
And it'll come in handy
when we want to authenticate
with Cloud IoT later on.
On the phone side, we need to
verify that the attestation
challenge is correct.
So we extract the attestation
from that certificate.
And then we create a hash
of the authentication token
from Nearby and the random
challenge we generated earlier.
And we combine them together,
and we generate a hash.
And we check that it matches
what came from the certificate
chain from the device.
And this sort of verifies
that this whole loop
is complete and secure.
And it's important,
because we never
actually sent the authentication
to the device directly.
It was done by Nearby.
And so this checks that
everything is done right
and that there's no man in
the middle attack happening
along the way.
So now we know that
the device is ours.
And that helps to deal
with all these issues
that we've identified.
So now the phone has verified
it can trust "TensorWash."
Now we need to authorize the
device on our Wi-Fi network.
And the quickest way
is just to pop up
an activity on your
phone and say, what's
the Wi-Fi SSID and passphrase?
But, of course, users
don't want to do that.
It's not very user-friendly.
And it requires the user to
enter their passphrase in.
And your app gets to see
the passphrase while it's
being sent over to the device.
And the next thing you do
is, on the device side,
you then need to use
the Wi-Fi Manager
to set the SSID and passphrase.
So this is a little code
snippet that does it.
However, Wi-Fi Manager is a
little bit more complicated.
So if you look at
the actual sample,
this is the code
you need to write
to talk to the Wi-Fi Manager.
So this is something
that we're working on
that we want to make a small
code library that you could use
that skips all this to make
it so that you don't have
to write that kind of code.
And we have some more
good news in that
we have an API called
Nearby Setup that's
coming to Google Play services.
And the great thing about Nearby
Setup, which is coming soon,
is that it has the ability
to take the Wi-Fi credentials
stored on your phone and pass
them to another devices, Google
Play services.
So Android Thing supports
Google Play services.
You can copy the
credentials over
without having to deal
with anything yourself.
The user doesn't
need to type them in.
And so this is great
for user convenience.
So this is coming soon.
And the details are going to be
on developers.google.com/nearby
later on when that's ready.
So we have internet access on
our device, and we have a key.
So now, let's quickly
talk about how
we're going to go about
talking and getting
cloud services enabled
on this device.
So we're going to talk about
Firebase and Cloud IoT.
So the first thing we need
to do is, on the phone side,
we need to set up Firebase.
Firebase is great, because it
works on Android, iOS, and web.
So the phone app could be
on many kinds of devices.
You create a
Firebase project ID.
And we're going to use that on
both the phone and the device.
And then, we ask the
phone user to authenticate
with their username and
password, pop up a dialog box,
and we'll get a
token that we then
pass down the encrypted pipe
that we created earlier.
So here is a bit of a
code snippet for it.
You can see at the top, we're
doing the sign-in request.
And it's interesting,
because we're only requesting
scope for the email ID.
So we don't want to
have full Google access
or access to their files or
email or anything like that.
We're just asking for their
identification details,
because we're trying
to limit scope,
like what Darren
talked about earlier.
We end up getting
a JSON web token
that we can then pass in
to sign in with Firebase,
which then allows our device to
interact with Firebase as well.
But we ship that token.
We shipped the previous
token off to the device
so it can log in to Firebase
and do things with that.
So on the other side, we
take the Google token,
pass it to Firebase and
authenticate with that.
And the device now has access to
the Firebase Realtime Database.
The code snippet looks very
similar on the device as well.
Because the Android Things
device is regular Android,
we use the same code, just
like we do on a phone.
We get the credential,
we pass it in
to sign in with credential
to Firebase auth,
and now we're done.
We now have a bi-directional
authorization.
And our "TensorWash"
now can fully
participate with the
Firebase Realtime Database.
So let's switch
gears to finish up.
We can also talk
to Cloud IoT Core.
So imagine you're running
a laundromat with thousands
of machines and
thousands of locations,
and you want to do predictive
breakdown analysis.
So we want to push the
data from these devices
to Cloud IoT for analysis.
So in Cloud IoT, we
register the devices.
You'd have an app on your
phone with some credentials.
And you would take
that public certificate
that we've created earlier,
and you would give that
to Cloud IoT so that
it knows the device
and that it can trust it.
We then use MQTT
to send requests
to Cloud IoT with our device
ID and signed with our key.
Cloud IoT can verify
that this message
is legitimate by
verifying this key
and checking it with
what it received earlier.
So then, we send the
MQT request using TLS.
And we use TLS so
that our device knows
that it can trust who is sending
the data to, because remember,
both sides need to
check the other side.
Here's a very quick
little snippet
that shows how we put in some
of the project IDs and things
like that.
And we're going to be
releasing the sample, too,
soon that shows how to do Cloud
IoT Core on Android Things.
And so the nice thing is
that publishDeviceState
at the bottom basically takes
any binary blob that you want
and sends it off to Cloud IoT.
And you don't have to
worry about generating
any of the messages.
So we talked very quickly
about Cloud IoT and Firebase.
What are some other options
of things you can do?
Well, we also have
Smart Home, which
is our new way of controlling
devices from the Google
Assistant.
So you can do things like,
if you've got light bulbs,
you can say, dim the
lights a little bit.
Or, in the case of
our washing machine,
if you implement
Smart Home, you can
do start my washing
machine, and it
will kick off a load of laundry
from the Google Assistant.
And so by implementing
Firebase, you
write a small web hook
that plugs into Smart Home.
And then your device
can be enabled
with the Google Assistant.
And then finally,
you can actually
embed the Google Assistant
SDK into your device, which
means you can actually
talk to the washing machine
and give it direct commands
to the machine directly,
which is kind of cool.
So what's next?
We have a factory key
provisioning store coming soon.
We're basically going to
have a hardware device that's
going to allow you to add keys
on to Android Things devices.
This is something
you could do yourself
or when they're being produced.
And this is how this key is
going to get onto the device.
So if you have a
developer kit, you
won't be able to test the
key signing correctly,
because you won't have an
official key from Android
Things.
But we're going to be
releasing the tools
to be able to do this soon.
And remember that Nearby Setup
API is coming soon as well.
And that's going to be really
nice to make provisioning
these things really easy.
So, in summary,
go visit our site
at androidthings.withgoogle.com,
which is a great community
site with lots of information.
We have a G+
community, g.co/iotdev,
where you can find
out more information,
and the Nearby site, where you
can keep track of what's coming
soon.
And also, follow
us on social media.
If you haven't had a chance,
go get yourself one of the IMX7
developer kits that we're
giving away here at Google I/O.
So make sure you
get one of those
you can try Android
Things out yourself,
because it's a really fun
development experience.
It's great for
making prototypes.
But it's also great for
making production devices.
That's it for us, so thanks
very much for coming.
And we'll see you all
around at the conference.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]